hey leute und herzlich willkommen wir zu
einem etwas anderen video was ich ein
paar leute von euch gewünscht haben und
zwar dass ich mein erstes video angucken
nicht dabei filme wie ich es angucke und
das video ist jetzt halt zwei jahre und
zwei monate her
das ist ein video das ich damals gemacht
habe wie man diamanten unter fünf
minuten bekommt wo damals heiß
diskutiert hat mittlerweile über 260.000
aufruf ich hab ich den link und eine
beschreibung gepackt und blende euch das
video auch hier ein während ich das
quasi gucke deswegen würde ich sagen
schauen wir mal an die können einfach
meine reaktion nicht ärgerte ich das
erste mal seit zwei jahren wieder an und
ist so heftig weil ich hab diesen
kommentar gelesen dass mir so was hab
ich echt gedacht jemand zu filmen die
ich meine alten videos angucken die
vielleicht so gespannt wie wir sagen wir
wollen jetzt einfach mal andere mit hey
leute in diesem video zeige ich euch
einfach mal vier in einer
zufallsgenerierte welt in minecraft eure
ersten diamanten innerhalb von nur fünf
minuten findet dafür erstelle ich mir
mal eben eine neue welt wie ihr gesehen
habt habe ich keinen zieht ein gegeben
das ist einfach aus dem grund damit die
pflicht genommen
den hat er vorher schon mal benutzt
hatte vorher schon geguckt oder ihre
hälse monaten
das ist alles komplett verändern hier du
willst dass ich mir holz hole das ist
dabei ist egal welches holz das ist das
kann diese hier sein das kann auch
dieses braune holz seines komplettes
kann diese eiche selbst vier holz holen
es wäre aber besser wenn ihr euch fünf
holz holt ihr könnt euch viel holen um
ein grund dass ich davon dass kinder
hatte die fcc darauf wie niedlich jetzt
mal eine workbench und mittlerweile
würde ich so was vorstellen ganz viele
scheiße so sagen so das alles aber ich
habe einfach so strikt und auch hier ab
und ich mache mir jetzt eine stein
schaufel und eine stein spitzhacke einen
stand auf neue sachen in der hand es ist
ein so und jetzt liegt es an euch ihr
könnt euch jetzt gibt es liegt an uns in
eurer minecraft welt suchen an dem ihr
euch einfach eine erde graben wollte ich
könnte mich natürlich jetzt auch schon
hier in der erde graben oder hier oder
hier einfach nicht danach aus das tier
unterhöhlen
wir sind daher in der nähe keine berge
sind also wenn ihr werke seht greift
euch am besten neben einem werk in den
boden dass es zu bedenken
ohne witz ist wirklich dass man in
tälern teils schneller unten ist ich
vorher den ort schon ausgeguckt also hab
ich nicht hab ich wirklich nicht so ist
auch gut so dann hole ich mir noch ein
paar steine hier damit ich komme ich
dich auf diese grafik klar
und wieder so gehakt hat das war doch
damals auf meinem laptop
ach so ich habe es halt die stein sachen
in steine verwaltung aber dann dauert
natürlich länger das was ich jetzt mache
ist nicht unbedingt notwendig empfehle
ich euch vor allem linien du mich mich
darunter graben eigentlich braucht man
ja sogar sondern stellt man sich in die
mitte von den beiden glück nicht stimmig
einfach trotzdem auf einen blick das
machte den unterschied
weil wenn ihr euch nur ein blog runter
grab system nicht was unter euch ist
deswegen kann es sein dass zwischendurch
mal einfach aber sie kommt und ich kann
jetzt einfach mal so lang und habe sich
kohl und heißen finde oder eine höhle
und da ist auch schon erste da haben wir
schon die kugeln
wo war gott leute ihr wissen ich bin
ganz so am zittern weil das ist einfach
2 1 2 jahren zwei monate all dieses
video
batbold hamburg gesehen dass es ihm zu
viel sagt sie denkt findet man bestimmt
auch noch unten aber ist natürlich gut
wenn es findet nehmen wir natürlich auch
alles mit brauchen wir später
und ja ich glaube ich übertreibe hier
gerade ein bisschen aber unnötig
darunter grabe alter ja da waren die
lecks in den pc und grad mich hier
weiter nach unten
wie gesagt ich hoffe einfach dass ich
gleich auf eine höhle stoße bzw
aufweisen bzw direkt schon einen
diamanten findet das halte ich zwar für
unrealistisch statt ihm diamanten
meistens erst auf der höhe
15 bzw 16 kommen gut erkannt luca aber
ich bin ja guten mutes er ist guten
mutes leute müssen auch außen weiter in
die tiefe bis sich auf ein höhlensystem
schlosser wenn ich aufhöre 15
beziehungsweise 16 und auch keine höhle
gefunden habe werde ich mich einfach in
die seite graben aber ein gewisser
london auf höhere 15 oder 16 immer auf
eine höhle
ich glaube zu dem zeitpunkt war ich
total motiviert weiterzumachen weil ich
nichts gefunden habe und die taktik
totalen einmal den bach runtergehen und
da haben auch schon erste zombie gehört
das heißt hier direkt nebenan muss eine
höhle sein und da haben wir auch schon
den lover see gefunden und wie ich das
nicht erkennen kann ist dass da hinten
sogar ein mops ponor weil da ist als
koppel stone und popsong deutet darauf
hin dass sein mops potter ist das seht
ihr da jetzt daher kommen wahrscheinlich
auch zombies ich versuche mir erstmal
ein lover ein weg über diese lover hier
zu bannen und wie ihr sicherlich merkt
ist das hier nachsynchronisiert
herzlichen glückwunsch an die die mir
wirklich noch so im grunde sind oft
probiert hat um das wirklich zeigen
doch deswegen sind wir knapp 40 44
ich habe das geschäft tatsächlich
natürlich hoch klar dass das ihr klappt
was ich hier sage also das muss nicht
unbedingt klappen
bei mir hat es bisher fast immer
geklappt ich versuche jetzt einfach mal
bei diesen blick herüber zu bauen
und da haben wir auch schalter da sind
die diamanten ist einfach mal vier mini
und 59 es heißt nämlich in dem video
auch dass ich euch zeige die man die
diamanten findet mir schon damals ganz
ausgeprägt für kleine lüge jetzt bevor
ihr den diamanten abbauen könnt euch
noch ein eisen spitzhacke machen also
damals man jemand nicht vertieft man es
mittlerweise sind so heftig dass
ziemlich schnell jemanden zu finden mit
diesem trick ich hoffe ihr habt euch das
video angeschaut und bis jetzt ungefähr
wie ich das mache dass ich mir schnell
diamanten finde
und ich sage einfach mal tschüss bis zum
nächsten video
das ist echt so kratzte sich jetzt so
das video anzugucken und es ist einfach
so lange her als es einfach durch es ist
einfach zwei jahre her da habe ich nicht
so angehört das ist ich finde sowas
immer geil so was zu hören von mir das
geil ich schäme mich dann immer so ein
bisschen der firma ist seit dem mega
witzig naja das letzte video was jetzt
halt nicht so viel arbeit war
ich muss dann wird um einen film mir das
angucken was wollten halt wirklich sehr
viele leute haben dass meine kommentare
geschrieben mit dem gesetz geschrieben
helga guck doch mal ein erstes video und
film sich dabei videos angucken sagt er
wirklich die 200 download der kommt 80
mehr kommen mache ich das mal gleiche
wenn die dass er auch mal ganz witzig
ich habe euch das video nochmal in die
beschreibung gepackt das video bei auf
die ganze zeit oben eingeblendet
hammergeil nicht witzig wie lange ich
eigentlich schon so dabei bin
das mega witzig vor allem ich mich so
verändert habe somit youtube zusammen
meine ganz veränderung ist auf youtube
vorhandenen megageil negerwitz ich nie
gute freunde schreibt immer bitte die
kommentare waren ihr nicht abonniert hat
also seit es jetzt vor zwei jahren oder
gestern oder übermorgen wenn das video
draußen kann er doch eines leute gucken
2000 sei nochmals reduziert denn ein
schreiner sowie ein mega witzig zu
wissen von wann ihr seid und dann hieß
es beim nächsten mal wieder tritt